and so while military engineers were
developing crossbow artillery and
powerful torsion catapults in the 4th
and 3rd centuries other engineers and
inventors were flocking to Alexandria
Egypt Alexandria Egypt at that time was
the Silicon Valley of antiquity that had
the museum the library and inventors
actually designed and constructed a
great variety of self moving devices
self-driving theaters complex automaton
some of the miniature some of them
colossal using mechanics and they even
had plans to use magnetism King Ptolemy
ii of alexandria commissioned their most
advanced designs for his magnificent
spectacles in alexandria his grand
procession of 279 BC it was a just an
outrageous parade of stunning
engineering marvels that wound through
the streets for days you can see the the
streets of Alexander Alexandria in this
lower lower right here and there were
many monumental life like animated
statues of gods and goddesses each on
carts pulled by 300 men on one cart for
example set a colossal 15 foot tall
goddess she was dressed in real silk
clothing sitting there regally on her
throne and then periodically along the
route of the parade this automaton stood
up poured a jug of milk into a large
bowl and then sat down again all a very
stately manner of course during his
reign King Ptolemy executed many members
of his family and his political enemies
he declared himself a god
but his automatons as far as we know
were nonviolent so those grandiose
spectacles of technology were intended
to drive home his godlike
absolute power
you